little news flash pop herald ain't so
perfect about that time in Puerto Rico
when we picked up those two like I said
with prostitutes but I don't remember
paying a person to but goddamn another
person - you're a war
Carrie I'm sorry Carrie wait I'm sorry
Carrie no don't you touch me - best ramp
oh sorry y'all go and slap somebody and
then apologize get some backbone I'll
tell you one thing you look seriously
happy here man
oh that's it my life is over
Stu it's okay what [ __ ] happens come on
this is not gonna know anything about
this this never happened I'll take care
come on shoot hey what's all that the
high rollers I have coffee mugs what you
have baseball caps huh and fancy
calendars all with pictures of Stu and
Jade and I realize we're all gonna lose
the people we love
that's the way it is but not me
not right now because the person I love
the most is standing right here and I'm
not ready to lose you yet Claire I'm not
standing here asking you to marry me I'm
just asking you not to marry him
it may be take a walk take a chance